हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है? प्लीज चैट में बता दीजिए।
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है? प्लीज
बता दीजिए।
ओके ओके वॉइस इज ओके एवरीथिंग वाज़ ओके
क्योंकि मेरी साइड में मैं देख पा रहा हूं
तो मेरी साइड में मे बी YouTube इज़
क्रिएटिंग सम प्रॉब्लम तो मैं एक बार मुझे
फिक्स करने दीजिए जस्ट गिव मी 30 सेकंड 30
टू 50 सेकंड तो तब तक के लिए बाकी
स्टूडेंट्स का वेट करते हैं उनको आने देते
हैं। अगर आपका कोई सवाल है, कोई क्वेश्चन
है रिलेटेड टू द क्लास तो आप मुझसे पूछ
सकते हो चैट बॉक्स में। मैं देख रहा हूं
आपके चैट।
आपका कोई सवाल है रिलेटेड टू प्रीवियस
क्लास?
प्रीवियस क्लास से रिलेटेड कोई भी सवाल है
आपका? प्लीज बता दीजिए मुझे। प्लीज बता
दीजिए।
देखो दो ही चीज हो सकती हैं। यह आपके
बिल्कुल डाउट क्लियर है। आपको सब कुछ
क्लियर सब कुछ समझ में आ गया या फिर आपके
ऊपर से गया। तो कौन से वाला क्लियर है
मुझे यह बताओ।
इफेक्टिव है यार। एनोनिमस इफेक्टिव है।
इफेक्टिव है। ऐसा नहीं है कि इफेक्टिव
नहीं है।
मैं पढ़ा क्यों रहा हूं? अगर इफेक्टिव
नहीं होगी तो अगर आप ओएससीपी जैसे एग्जाम
दोगे तो वहां पर भी इनके पे लोड आपको यूज़
करने पड़ सकते हैं। देन क्या करोगे?
एग्जाम पास करने नहीं करने हैं।
या वेरी गुड इवनिंग।
सबको गुड इवनिंग अगेन।
तो गाइस एक बार मुझे स्पीड चेक करने दीजिए
इंटरनेट की। ओके
हम
आपको कोई बफरिंग तो नहीं हो रही? कोई वॉइस
की प्रॉब्लम, कोई वीडियो बफरिंग वगैरह ऐसा
कुछ इशू तो नहीं हो रहा आप लोगों को?
प्लीज मुझे वो बताइए। आपकी साइड में कोई
इशू नहीं आ रहा ना? मेरी साइड से?
सब कुछ सही चल रहा है?
सब ओके ओके इफ यू क्राई क्या होता है
अनोनिमस इफ यू क्राई मींस
यार मैंने तो किया नहीं है। इंग्लिश
ट्रांसलेशन ऑटोमेटिक हो रहा होगा मेबी।
ऑप्शन
चलिए फिर मैं अभी आपकी चैट नहीं देख
पाऊंगा। चैट के लिए मैं बाद में देखना
पड़ेगा। बिकॉज़ दूसरे डिवाइस पर मेरा चीजें
काम नहीं कर रही। तो आज हम बात करते हैं
डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट एंड वीबीए के बारे में।
सो चलिए फिर स्टार्ट करते हैं। मैं अपनी
पेंसिल को ओपन कर लेता हूं। तो जैसे कि
प्रीवियस क्लास में हमने वीबीए मैक के
बारे में काफी कुछ पढ़ा था कि वीबीए मैक
होता क्या है? क्योंकि दो क्लासेस हम
फंडामेंटल्स में कवर कर चुके हैं। अभी हम
बात करने वाले हैं किसके बारे में?
डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट एंड वीबीए के बारे में।
ओके? तो सबसे पहले जैसा कि मैंने आपको कल
बताया था कि एक फंडामेंटल कंफ्यूजन होता
है। उस कंफ्यूजन को आपको क्लियर रखना है।
वो कंफ्यूजन क्या है कि जो आपका
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है आपका जो डब्ल्यू
स्क्रिप्ट है डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट आपका क्या
नहीं है? आपका वीबीए नहीं है। डब्ल्यू
स्क्रिप्ट आपका वीबीए नहीं है। नॉट वीबीए
डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट इज
नॉट वीबीए आपका जो डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट है
वह वीबीए नहीं है। तो आपका डब्ल्यू
स्क्रिप्ट क्या है? क्या नहीं है? इसके
बारे में हम बात करते हैं। तो इसके बारे
में बात करते हैं। तो एक मिनट।
चलो मैं आपकी चैट ही देख लेता हूं ओनली।
तो डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट होता क्या है? इसके
बारे में बात करते हैं। डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
एंड वीबी इंटीग्रेशन। डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट इज
अ Windows स्क्रिप्ट होस्ट ऑब्जेक्ट
ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल दैट प्रोवाइड्स ए
स्क्रिप्टिंग एनवायरमेंट फॉर
एग्जीक्यूटिंग स्क्रिप्ट ऑन Windows बेस्ड
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम। मतलब क्या है कि जो
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है, डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट को
हम बोलते हैं Windows स्क्रिप्टिंग
Windows स्क्रिप्ट होस्ट। यह Windows
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का एक ऑब्जेक्ट ऑब्जेक्ट
मॉडल और स्क्रिप्टिंग एनवायरमेंट है। क्या
है? एक तो ये ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल है। दूसरा
स्क्रिप्टिंग एनवायरमेंट है। जो
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
आपका एक ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल है। साथ में एक
स्क्रिप्टिंग एनवायरमेंट है Windows
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर। तो अभी जैसा कि
हमने कल एक बार बताया था। मैं आपको रिपीट
कर देता हूं क्योंकि टॉपिक को बिल्कुल
स्टार्टिंग से समझाता हूं मैं। जो आपका जो
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स है, Windows
में आपको दो तरह से काम करते हो। Windows
में आप दो तरह से काम करते हो। पहला क्या
है आपका? जीयूआई। ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफ़ेस
पे काम करते हो। ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफ़ेस
में क्या करते हो आप? आप जैसे माउस से डबल
क्लिक करते हो किसी भी एप्लीकेशन के ऊपर,
किसी आइकॉन के ऊपर, किसी फोल्डर के ऊपर,
किसी फाइल के ऊपर वो फाइल ओपन हो जाती है।
तो, वह आपका ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफ़ेस। दूसरा
काम करते हो आप सीएलआई से। दूसरा काम करते
हो आप सीएलआई से। सीएलआई से आप दूसरा काम
करते हो सीएलआई से। अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सीएलआई से
क्या करते हो आप? सीएलआई से आप अपना
ऑटोमेटिक काम परफॉर्म करते हो। जो
ऑटोमेटिक टास्क है वो परफॉर्म करते हो।
चैट मैं अभी बाद में लूंगा। प्लीज प्लीज
प्लीज प्लीज प्लीज मैं अभी सही से आपकी
चैट नहीं देख पा रहा। ओके। सही से मैं
आपकी चैट नहीं देख पा रहा। तो जैसा कि मैं
आपको बताया था कि Windows में आप दो तरीके
से काम करते हो। एक तो ग्राफिकल यूजर
इंटरफेस से दूसरा करते हो सीएलआई से।
सीएलआई में आप क्या करते हो? ऑटोमेशन
परफॉर्म करते हो। कोई स्क्रिप्ट लिखते हो,
कोई कोड लिखते हो या पावर सेल स्क्रिप्ट
लिखते हो या आप वीबीएस स्क्रिप्ट लिखते हो
या जेएस स्क्रिप्ट लिखकर आप क्या करते हो?
अपना काम ऑटोमेटिक परफॉर्म करवा सकते हो।
तो नॉर्मल यूजर के लिए जो ग्राफिकल यूजर
इंटरफेस है उसकी कोई दिक्कत नहीं है।
नॉर्मल यूजर्स के लिए जो जीयूआई है हम बात
करें नॉर्मल यूजर जो नॉर्मल यूजर है उसके
लिए ये ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफेस सही है। कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। लेकिन जब बात आती है
किसकी? आपके सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स की।
जब बात आती है आपके प्रोग्रामर्स की। उसको
क्या करना पड़ता है? आपकी डेली रोजमर्रा
की जिंदगी में आपको डेली बेसिस पे उसको
क्या करना करने पड़ते हैं? बहुत सारी ऐसी
रिक्वायरमेंट फुलफिल करनी पड़ती है जहां
पर उसको ऑटोमेशन की रिक्वायरमेंट होती है
और उसी ऑटोमेशन को परफॉर्म करने के लिए वो
किसका यूज़ करता है? डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट का
यूज़ करता है। ओके? और डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
किसने बनाया? Microsoft window microsoft
windows ने। बेसिकली मतलब यह है कि जो
सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स हैं जो आपके
प्रोग्रामर्स हैं उनकी लाइफ को इजी बनाने
के लिए उनके काम को ऑटोमेशन प्रोवाइड करने
के लिए Windows ने डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट को
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट को बनाया। किसको बनाया?
डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट को। ठीक है? डब्लू
स्क्रिप्ट को क्या किया? Windows ने डेवलप
किया। ठीक है? Windows host स्क्रिप्ट को
किसने किया? Microsoft Windows ने उसको
डेवलप किया। किसके लिए? आपके प्रोग्रामर
या जो सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेशन है उसकी लाइफ
को आसान बनाने के लिए। मे बी फर्स्ट लाइन
आपको क्लियर हो गई होगी। इट अलाउ यूज़र्स
टू रन स्क्रिप्ट विद इन द स्क्रिप्टिंग
लैंग्वेज सच एज वीए एंड जेस्क्रिप्ट
डायरेक्टली फ्रॉम द कमांड लाइन और एज
पार्ट ऑफ ऑटोमेटेड प्रोसेस। मतलब क्या है
कि जो यह डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट है यह किसी भी
यूजर को Windows के ऊपर स्क्रिप्ट लाइक
वीबी स्क्रिप्ट वीबी स्क्रिप्ट डॉट vb
स्क्रिप्ट जिसको हम बोल सकते हैं डॉट
वीबीएस स्क्रिप्ट और दूसरा jवास्क्रिप्ट
डॉट जेएस स्क्रिप्ट डॉट जेएस स्क्रिप्ट
मतलब जो डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट है वो किसी भी
यूजर को Windows के ऊपर स्क्रिप्ट जैसे
वीबीएस स्क्रिप्ट या डॉट जेएस स्क्रिप्ट
जिसको हम वीबी स्क्रिप्ट बोलते हैं या जो
जावास्क्रिप्ट बोलते हैं उनको डायरेक्ट
कमांड लाइन या ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम लेवल पर
एग्जीक्यूट करने के लिए अलऊ करता है। मतलब
मतलब यह है कि जो डॉट वीबीएस है या डॉट
जेएस स्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से आप कमांड ले
कमांड लाइन के थ्रू ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम लेवल
के टास्क परफॉर्म कर सकते हो विद दी हेल्प
ऑफ डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट। और जो
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है वो Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के अंदर एक बिल्ड इन प्रोग्राम है।
ठीक है? जो डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है यह
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के लिए एक बिल्ड
इन प्रोग्राम है। एक बिल्ड इन सॉफ्टवेयर
है जो पहले से ही इंस्टॉल मिलता है। इसको
बाहर से इंस्टॉल करने की जरूरत नहीं
पड़ती। कि जब आप विंडो इंस्टॉल करते हो या
जो आपका माइक्रो सॉरी आप जब विंडो इंस्टॉल
करते हो उसी टाइम पे वो इंस्टॉल हो जाता
है। इसको आपको अलग से कहीं से इंस्टॉल
करने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ती।
ओके? उसको जरूरत नहीं पड़ती। तो नाउ
नेक्स्ट पॉइंट पर आते हैं।
तो नेक्स्ट पॉइंट पर आने से पहले मैं आपको
एक चीज समझा देता हूं कि जो आपका कंप्यूटर
है जो आपका कंप्यूटर है वह जो वीबीएस
स्क्रिप्ट है और आपकी जो जेएस स्क्रिप्ट
है इसके अंदर जो भी कोड लिखा जाता है
जिसको आप जो भी चाहे वो विजुअल बेसिक में
लिखा जाए चाहे वह जेएस में लिखा जाए जो भी
कोड लिखा जाता है एक प्रकार से है तो एक
टेक्स्ट टाइप का ही वह तो उसको जो आपका
कंप्यूटर है वह डायरेक्टली समझ नहीं पाता
उसको डायरेक्टली समझ नहीं पाता। तो उसके
लिए जो डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है वह क्या करती
है? सबसे पहले वो जो जो डॉट वीबीएस है या
डॉट जेएस फाइल है उसको रीड करती है। रीड
करने के बाद मतलब उसको रीड करती है और उस
फाइल के अंदर एक-एक कमांड या एक-एक कोड को
क्या करती है? वो पढ़ती है डब्ल्यूस्किप
उसको ट्रांसलेट करती है और ट्रांसलेट करने
के बाद जो Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को इंस्ट्रक्शन
पास करती है कि अभी आपको क्या करना है?
क्या इस कोड को पढ़ने के बाद आपको क्या
स्क्रीन पर कोई पॉपअप दिखाना है, कोई
फोल्डर बनाना है या कोई एप्लीकेशन ल्च
करनी है। कोई फोल्डर बनाना है, कोई पॉपअप
करना है या कोई एप्लीकेशन ल्च करनी है।
बेस्ड ऑन दैट कोड। मतलब क्या किया? आपने
जो कोड प्रोवाइड किया है उसको आपका जो
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है लाइन बाय लाइन कोड
बाय कोड उसको रीड करता है ट्रांसलेट करता
है उसके बाद उसके बेसिस पर विंडो को क्या
करता है इंस्ट्रक्शन देता है कि भैया अभी
करना क्या है इसका ओके भैया इसका करना
क्या है ये चीज क्या है डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
क्या करती है ट्रांसलेशन काम करती है बीच
में एक ब्रिज का काम करती है आपका जो
विंडो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स है यह आपका
विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है और बीच में
आपकी जो ये एप्लीकेशनेशंस है इसके बीच में
ब्रिज का काम क्या करता है आपका?
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट। ब्रिज का काम क्या करता
है आपका? डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट। तो नेक्स्ट
पॉइंट पे बात करते हैं। इन द कॉन्टेक्स्ट
ऑफ विजुअल बेसिक्स फॉर एप्लीकेशन।
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट कैन बी यूटिलाइज टू
एक्सटेंड द कैपेबिलिटीज ऑफ वीबीए मैस बाय
इनेबलिंग देम टू इंटैक्ट विद द विंडोज
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम, एग्जीक्यूट एक्सटर्नल
कमांड्स, मैनपुलेट फाइल्स एंड फोल्डर्स
एंड परफॉर्म अदर सिस्टम रिलेटेड टास्क।
इसका मतलब क्या है? कि जो अगर हम बात करें
कि जो विजुअल बेसिक्स है उसके कॉन्टेक्स्ट
में बात करें जैसा कि आपको पता है जो
वीबीए है वो वीबीए आपकी जो ऑफिस एप्लीकेशन
है जैसे आपका Microsoft ऑफिस है जैसे
Microsoft आपका वर्ड है, एक्सेल है, पावर
है या आपका
प्रेजेंटेशन है। ठीक है? तो उन्हीं तक ही
क्या है? आपका जो वीबीए है वो
रिस्ट्रिक्टेड है। मतलब जैसे कि मैं पहले
बता चुका हूं। हमने क्या पढ़ा था कि उसकी
लिमिट किसके अंदर है? उस Microsoft ऑफिस
शट के अंदर उसकी लिमिट है। उसी घर तक वो
लिमिट है। फिर भी क्योंकि क्यों उसकी
लिमिट? क्यों? क्योंकि उसका जो प्राइमरी
काम क्या है? प्राइमरी काम उसका है कि
डॉक्यूमेंट को जैसे कि फॉर्मेट करना,
टेक्स्ट को फॉर्मेट करना, टेबल्स बनाना,
एक्सेल शील्ड्स को कैलकुलेट करना। ऐसे
बेसिक-बेसिक काम करना उसका
प्राइमरी काम है। किसके अंदर? आपके
Microsoft Office के अंदर, आपके Microsoft
एक्सेल के अंदर, आपके पावर पॉइंट के अंदर।
तो, यह सारे बेसिक काम करने के लिए जो आप
डेली बेसिस पर करते हो, उसको ऑटोमेटिक
करता है विद दी हेल्प ऑफ आपका वीबीए।
वीबीए की हेल्प से आप क्या कर सकते हो? एक
स्क्रिप्ट लिख देते हो। तो, यह सारी चीजें
आपको बार-बार नहीं करनी पड़े। इसलिए आप इस
टाइप की ये चीजें करते हो। इसीलिए क्या है
कि जो वीबीए है वह Microsoft ऑफिस सूट तक
ही लिमिटेड है क्योंकि उसका जो प्राइमरी
काम है उस उस काम को देखते हुए उसकी जो
लिमिटेशन है Microsoft ऑफिस तक ही है
क्योंकि उससे बाहर उसको रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं
है। उसके बाहर भी जो Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम्स है उसके ऊपर भी उसका बहुत ज्यादा
लिमिटेड कंट्रोल है। बहुत ही ज्यादा उसकी
जो फंक्शनलिटी बहुत ज्यादा लिमिटेड है।
मतलब Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम पर उसकी खास
कोई फंक्शनैलिटी नहीं है। लेकिन फिर भी
अगर जो वीबीए है फिर भी अगर आपका जो
विजुअल बेसिक्स है उसको
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम से जो होस्ट
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स है उसके साथ
अगर उसको इंटैक्ट करना भी पड़ जाए अगर
उसको उसके साथ इंटैक्ट करना भी है तो वो
कैसे करेगा? फॉर एग्जांपल्स अगर किसी हैकर
या डेवलपर को वीबीए की हेल्प से Microsoft
Word के बाहर निकलकर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम पर
कुछ टास्क परफॉर्म करने हैं। जैसे Windows
रजिस्ट्री में कुछ चेंज करना है, सिस्टम्स
कमांड चलानी है या कंप्यूटर में किसी
दूसरी जगह से फाइल को रीड राइट या
एग्जीक्यूट करना है, डिलीट करना है या
इंटरनेट से कोई फाइल डाउनलोड करवानी है तो
वो कैसे करेगा? वो क्या करेगा? डब्ल्यू
स्क्रिप्ट की यूज के का यूज करेगा जो
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है उसकी हेल्प लेगा उसकी
मदद लेगा उसकी मदद से ही कर पाएगा क्योंकि
जो वीबीए है उसके पास पास ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
के साथ डायरेक्ट
जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है उसके साथ डायरेक्ट
कम्युनिकेट करने के या डायरेक्ट कम
कम्युनिकेट करने की ऐसी कोई पावर नहीं है
किसके पास वीबीआई के पास तो ये चीज सबको
क्लियर है यहां तक कि डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट
क्या है
सबको क्लियर है डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट होती
क्या है अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन हां स्टूडेंट आए
नहीं पता नहीं कहां चले गए संडे मनाने के
लिए गए हैं ना क्योंकि बिकॉज़ इट इज वेरी
बोरिंग टॉपिक
जल्दी से आंसर कीजिए चैट में आपको सबको
क्लियर क्लियर है?
ओके। थ्योरी है इसलिए आप लोग नहीं आओगे।
प्रैक्टिकल होता तो आप आते ना।
कोई बात नहीं दोस्त।
मत पढ़ो थ्योरी। आज के जनरेशन को थ्योरी से
नफरत है ना?
आपकी फर्स्ट क्लास है क्या आपकी? अनिरुद्ध
चौधरी।
अनिरुद्ध चौधरी आपकी फर्स्ट क्लास है
क्या?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
आपकी फर्स्ट क्लास है इसलिए आप पूछ रहे हो
कि वीबीए क्या होता है? तो प्लीज मैं आपसे
एक रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा। रिक्वेस्ट यह है कि
ऑलरेडी दो क्लास हो चुकी है। डे 74, क्लास
74 और क्लास 73 दोनों में वीबीए के बारे
में काफी अच्छे से डिस्कशन किया गया है।
चलिए तो अभी हम बात करते हैं की
कैपेबिलिटीज ऑफ डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट वाया
वीबीए। अभी जो डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है उसकी
कैपेबिलिटीज़ के बारे में बात करते हैं।
फॉर योर काइंड इनेशन आपको यह भी बताऊंगा
आपको कि वीबीए क्या-क्या कर सकती है?
वीबीए क्या-क्या कर सकता है यह भी आपको
बताऊंगा।
चलिए तो सबसे पहले हम बात करते हैं
एक्सेसिंग डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट ऑब्जेक्ट
मॉडल। इन वीबीए मैक यू कैन क्रिएट एन
इंस्टेंस ऑफ द डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट ऑब्जेक्ट
टू एक्सेस इट्स प्रॉपर्टीज एंड मेथड्स।
अगर आपको वीबीए के अंदर वीबीए मैक के अंदर
अगर डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट जो आपका
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट ऑब्जेक्ट है उसको एक्सेस
करना है उसके उसकी जो भी मेथड्स हैं उसकी
जो भी प्रॉपर्टीज हैं अगर उनको एक्सेस
करना है तो एक्सेस करने के लिए क्या करना
पड़ेगा उसका एक ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट करना
पड़ेगा एक इंस्टेंस क्रिएट करना पड़ेगा
आपको अपने कोड के अंदर वह मैं आपको करके
दिखाऊंगा प्रैक्टिकली लेकिन मेरे कहने का
मतलब क्या है कि अगर आपको वीबी ए मैक्रो
के अंदर डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट को यूज करना
है। उसकी प्रॉपर्टीज और उसके मेथड को यूज़
करना है। तो आपको उसका एक इंस्टेंस क्रिएट
करना पड़ेगा। किसके अंदर? आपके वीबीए मैक
कोड के अंदर। दिस अलाउ यू टू परफॉर्म
वेरियस सिस्टम लेवल ऑपरेशंस। और जब आप
उसको एक्सेस कर लेते हो, उसका इंस्टेंस
क्रिएट कर लेते हो, तब आप उसके साथ बहुत
सारी चीजें कर सकते हो। जैसे कि आप
मैसेजेस को डिस्प्ले कर सकते हो। उनके
सिस्टम के एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल्स को क्या
कर सकते हो? रीड कर सकते हो या जो
एक्सटर्नल प्रोग्राम्स हैं उनको रन कर
सकते हो, एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हो। नाउ
पॉइंट नंबर टू डिस्प्लेइंग मैसेजेस यूजिंग
डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट यू कैन डिस्प्ले डायलॉग
बॉक्सेस एंड मैसेजेस टू इंटैक्ट विद यूजर
ड्यूरिंग द एग्जीक्यूशन ऑफ वीबीए मैक।
मतलब क्या है कि डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट का यूज
करके आप वीबीए मैक के एग्जीक्यूशन के
दौरान आप डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट का यूज करके
वीबीए मै एग्जीक्यूशन के दौरान यूजर के
साथ इंटैक्ट करने के लिए आप क्या कर सकते
हो जो डायलॉग बॉक्सेस हैं या जो मैसेज
डिस्प्ले है उनका यूज़ कर सकते हो। क्या
है? मैसेज डिस्प्ले का यूज़ कर सकते हो।
मतलब क्या मतलब यह है कि अगर आप
वीबीए कोड यूज कर रहे हो मशियस वीबीए कोड
यूज कर रहे हो और आपको क्या करना है अगर
यूजर को ट्रिक करना है यूजर से क्लिक
करवाना है तो क्या कर सकते हो
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से आप ड्यूरिंग
वीबीए मै एग्जीक्यूशन आप यूजर के साइंट
करने के लिए डायलॉग बॉक्सेस पॉप अप करवा
सकते हो कोई मैसेज पॉप अप करवा सकते हो
विद दी हेल्प ऑफ डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट जैसे कि
इंफॉर्मेटिव मैसेजेस वार्निंग प्र्प फॉर
यूजर इनपुट या एरर ऑर्डर जैसे कि आप क्या
कर सकते हो कोई इंफॉर्मेशन मैसेज पॉप अप
करवा सकते हो कोई वार्निंग पॉप अप करवा
सकते हो कोई यूजर इनपुट ले सकते हो या कोई
एरर नोटिफिकेशन आप पॉप अप करवा सकते हो
फॉर एग्जांपल अगर हम रेड टीमिंग के
कॉन्टेक्स्ट में बात करें अगर मैं रेड
टीमिंग के कॉन्टेक्स्ट में समझाऊं कि हैकर
बैकग्राउंड में क्या कर सकते हैं पेलोड
एग्जीक्यूशन के दौरान एक फेक विंडोज
सिक्योरिटी ्योरिटी पॉप अप दिखा सकते हैं।
पेलोड एग्जीक्यूशन के दौरान एक फेक विंडोज
पॉप अप दिखा सकते हैं। जैसे कि फॉर
एग्जांपल योर ऑफिस लाइसेंस नीड टू बी
अपडेट। प्लीज ओके टू कंटिन्यू कि आप आपने
क्या किया? पॉप अप करवाया। पॉप अप में
जैसे ही उसने क्या किया? आपका अपनी वर्ड
फाइल को ओपन किया। ओपन करते ही एक पॉपअप
मैसेज आया। योर Microsoft Office लाइसेंस
नीड टू बी अपडेटेड। क्लिक ओके टू
कंटिन्यू। इस तरीके से आप क्या करवा सकते
हो? विद दी हेल्प ऑफ अ अह
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट इस टाइप के पॉपअप आप
जनरेट करवा सकते हो। और जब तक यूजर उस
पॉपअप वाले ओके बटन पर क्लिक करेगा तब तक
बैकग्राउंड में ऑटोमेटिकली क्या होगा? एक
पेलोड ड्रॉप हो चुका होगा। मतलब सोचेगा ना
पहले कुछ 3 सेकंड 2 सेकंड 10 सेकंड 5
सेकंड तो सोचेगा ही क्लिक करने से पहले
ऐसा क्यों अभी तक तो था चेक करेगा तो वो
ओके करने से पहले तब तक तो आप क्या करवा
लोगे एक पेलोड भी ड्रॉप कर सकते हो तो यह
एक एग्जांपल है रेड टीमिंग के कॉन्टेक्स्ट
में ये आपका एक एग्जांपल है रेड टीमिंग के
कॉन्टेक्स्ट में नेक्स्ट पॉइंट नंबर थ्री
रनिंग एक्सटर्नल प्रोग्राम्स डब्ल्यू
स्क्रिप्ट इनेबल्स वीबीए मैक्रोस टू
एग्जीक्यूट एक्सटर्नल प्रोग्राम्स और
कमांड्स डायरेक्टली फ्रॉम विद इन द ऑफिस
एप्लीकेशन।
फ्रॉम द ऑफिस एप्लीकेशन। इसका मतलब क्या
है? कि डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट की मदद से आप
वीबीए मै के जरिए किसी भी ऑफिस एप्लीकेशन
के अंदर से डायरेक्ट कोई भी प्रोग्राम या
कमांड एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हैं। ऑफिस
एप्लीकेशन के अंदर से ही कोई भी प्रोग्राम
कोई भी कमांड डायरेक्टली एग्जीक्यूट करवा
सकते हो विद दी हेल्प ऑफ ए वीबीए। एंड दिस
कैपेबिलिटी इज यूजफुल फॉर ऑटोमेटिंग टास्क
दैट रिक्वायर इंटरेक्शन विद अदर
एप्लीकेशनेशंस और एग्जीक्यूटिंग सिस्टम
सिस्टम यूटिलिटीज और यह जो कैपेबिलिटी है
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट की यह बहुत ही खतरनाक और
पावरफुल कैपेबिलिटी है क्योंकि आप क्या कर
सकते हो इससे डायरेक्ट कोई भी एप्लीकेशन
ल्च करवा सकते हो कोई भी कोड एग्जीक्यूट
करवा सकते हो या यह जो कैपेबिलिटी है आपकी
की वो वो सारे टास्क क्या है जो भी टास्क
है उनको ऑटोमेट करने के लिए काफी यूज़फुल
होती है। जैसे कि आपका आपको क्या करना है?
किसी दूसरी एप्लीकेशन के साथ इंटैक्ट करना
है तब भी यह कैपेबिलिटी बहुत काम आ सकती
है। या फिर आपको क्या करना है कि सिस्टम
के अंदर जो डिफॉल्ट यूटिलिटीज हैं, सिस्टम
के अंदर जो कमांड्स हैं, उनकी हेल्प से
आपको कुछ डेटा चाहिए आपकी
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट के अंदर ऑटोमेटिकली आप कमांड
लाइन ओपन ना करनी करनी पड़े। तब भी क्या
है कि यह जो कैपेबिलिटी है
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट की काफी काम काम आती है।
और जब हम बात करें रेड इमिंग के
कॉन्टेक्स्ट में बात करें तो अटैकर्स इसका
यूज़ करके जो नेटिव यूटिलिटीज है उनको
हाईजैक कर सकते हैं। नेटिव यूटिलिटीज क्या
होती है कि जो बाय डिफॉल्ट जो कमांड्स
होती है विंडोज के अंदर जो एडमिन लेवल की
कमांड्स है जो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स यूज़ करते
हैं डेली बेसिस के काम करने के लिए उनको
आप क्या कर सकते हो? हाईजैक कर सकते हो
विद दी हेल्प ऑफ ए दिस
डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट। ओके? और जो
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है वो या आप क्या कर
सकते हो जो डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से
Windows की जो बिल्ट इन कमांड्स हैं उनका
यूज़ करके क्या कर सकते हो कमांड एंड
कंट्रोल सर्वर जिसको C2 सर्वर भी बोलते
हैं उससे क्या कर सकते हो रिवर्स सेल
सेटअप कर सकते हो या फिर आपका जो ट्रोजन
है वो डाउनलोड करवा सकते हो
क्या कर सकते हो नेटिव यूटिलिटीज को
हाईजैक कर सकते हो या जो डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
की हेल्प से Windows की आप इनबिन कम कमांड
को यूज़ करके C2 सर्वर के साथ रिवर्स
कनेक्शन सेट कर सकते हो या रेट जिसको बोल
सकते हैं हम रिमोट एक्सेस ट्रोजन डाउनलोड
करवा सकते हो। तो ये इसकी कैपेबिलिटीज है
किसकी? आपकी डब्ल्यूस्किप्ट की। अंडरस्टुड
एवरीवन? समझ में आ गया? कि डब्ल्यूस्किप्ट
के साथ आप किस के साथ क्या-क्या कर सकते
हो। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? समझ में आया? यह
तीनों पॉइंट क्लियर है?
यह तीनों पॉइंट क्लियर है सबको?
यह तीनों पॉइंट क्लियर है सबको? बताओ
जल्दी से।
तो वही तो आपको बाईपास करवाना है ना
इनेबल।
इनेबल आपको करवाना है। उसी का वही तो खेल
है पूरा ट्रिक सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में।
क्लाइंट एंड अटैक्स में आपको सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग परफॉर्म करनी है और सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में आपको प्री टेक्स्ट यूज़
करना है और प्री टेक्स्ट आपका जितना
स्ट्रांग सॉलिड होगा, जितना विश्वास करने
लायक होगा, उतना ही यूज़र्स को आप ट्रिक कर
पाओगे।
समझ पाए? प्रिटेक्स्ट का खेल है।
आई एम सॉरी। मैं इंग्लिश में नहीं पढ़ा
सकता।
बिकॉज़ यह हिंदी की क्लासेस हैं। तो हिंदी
में ही पढ़ाया जाएगा।
जी बोलिए। एक और सवाल आप लोग पूछ रहे थे।
तो सबको क्लियर है यहां तक या किसी को कोई
डाउट है? प्लीज लेट मी नो।
किसी को कोई भी डाउट है तो प्लीज पूछ
लीजिए।
कोई डाउट है यहां तक?
चलिए अभी हम बात करते हैं व्हाई इज विंडोज
स्क्रिप्ट डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्टेंट फॉर
हैकर्स एंड रेड टीमर्स?
कि हैकर्स और रेड टीमर्स के लिए डब्ल्यू
स्क्रिप्ट क्यों इंपॉर्टेंट है?
जब भी हम फिशिंग और मशियस पेलोड में की
बात करते हैं तो डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट हैकर्स
का फेवरेट टूल क्यों रहा है? जब भी हम बात
मेरा सवाल यह है कि अगर जब भी हम फिशिंग
या मिशस पेलोड की बात करते हैं तो जो
डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट है वह हैकर्स का फेवरेट
टूल्स क्यों रहा है? क्यों रहा है? ठीक
है?
पेलोड ड्रॉप कैसे होगा? आई विल शो इन
प्रैक्टिकली डोंट वरी।
ओके तो इसके तीन रीज़न हैं। इसके मेनली तीन
रीज़न है। सबसे पहला रीज़न है नेटिव Windows
यूटिलिटी। WS स्क्रिप्ट कम्स प्रीइस्टॉल्ड
ऑन एव्री Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स
इंक्लूडिंग Windows 7, Windows 10,
Windows 11 एंड सर्वर एडिशनंस। अटैकर्स डू
नॉट नीड टू इंस्टॉल एनी एक्सटर्नल
सॉफ्टवेयर ऑन द टारगेट सिस्टम। तो सबसे
पहला और मेन रीजन क्या है कि जो
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है वो हर एक Windows
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम पर पहले से प्रीइस्टॉल्ड
आता है। हैकर्स को या किसी भी पेंट को
पेंटेस्टर को टारगेट पीसी के अंदर इसको
अलग से इंस्टॉल करने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ती।
दूसरा डायरेक्ट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
इंटीग्रेशन डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट फीचर्स
एक्सट्रीमली पावरफुल बिल्ट इन ऑब्जेक्ट्स
दिस कैपेबिलिटी अलव इट टू एग्जीक्यूट
साइलेंट बैकग्राउंड प्रोसेससेस क्योंकि जो
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है उसके पास बहुत ही
पावरफुल ऑब्जेक्ट्स होते हैं। मतलब कि आप
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से साइलेंटली
बैकग्राउंड में प्रोसेससेस को रन कर सकते
हैं। एंड रीड राइट एंड डिलीट फाइल्स। आप
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से फाइल्स को
रीड राइट डिलीट कर सकते हैं। आप क्या कर
सकते हो? डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से
Windows रजिस्ट्री कीज़ को मॉडिफाई कर सकते
हैं। आप फोर्थ वन क्या कर सकते हो?
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से से इंटरनेट
से फाइल को डाउनलोड करके एग्जीक्यूट कर
सकते हैं। मतलब मैंने कि आप
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से साइलेंटली
बैकग्राउंड में कोई भी प्रोसेस रन कर सकते
हैं। फाइल को रीड राइट डिलीट कर सकते हैं।
Windows रजिस्ट्रीज को मॉडिफाई कर सकते
हैं। रीड कर सकते हैं या इंटरनेट से फाइल
डाउनलोड करके एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हैं। ये
सारे काम क्या कर सकते हो आप?
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से कर सकते हो।
तो इसीलिए भी सेकंड पॉइंट इसलिए भी ये
क्या है? हैकर्स का फेवरेट या रेटिमर्स का
फेवरेट टूल रहा है। ठीक है? ये रेटिमर्स
का फेवरेट टूल्स रहा है। तीसरा पॉइंट क्या
है कि मैक इंटीग्रेशन मैक इंटीग्रेशन। ठीक
है? व्हेन एग्जीक्यूटिंग मैच इन मॉडर्न
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिस एनवायरमेंट्स। मॉडर्न
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिस एनवायरमेंट्स।
अटैकर्स टिपिकली अवॉयड ओपनिंग ए डायरेक्ट
टर्मिनल वाया वीबीए कोड। मतलब क्या है कि
जो मॉडर्न माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिसिसेस होते हैं
उसमें जब मै कोड एग्जीक्यूट होता है तो
हैकर्स अक्सर क्या करते हैं? जो वीबीए कोड
है उसके जरिए डायरेक्ट टर्मिनल को नहीं
खोलते। ठीक है? वह डायरेक्ट टर्मिनल को
नहीं खोलते। कि वह नहीं चाहते कि जैसे ही
वीबीए कोड हो और जो टर्मिनल है आपका पावर
सेल टर्मिनल है या आपका जो वीबी आपका
कमांड cmd exec टर्मिनल है वो पॉप अप हो
वो नहीं चाहते वो क्या करते हैं इंस्टेंट
दे इनवोक wsिपexc
फ्रॉम विद इन द वीबीएस स्क्रिप्ट टू ड्रॉप
ए स्मॉल वीबीएस फाइल व्हिच क्वाइटली
डाउनलोड एंड एग्जीक्यूट द मेन पेलोड इन द
बैकग्राउंड वह क्या करते हैं वीबीए की
हेल्प से चुपचाप जो डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट है
उसको कॉल करते हैं। एक छोटी सी डॉट वीबीएस
फाइल को ड्रॉप करते हैं और ड्रॉप करने के
बाद वो क्या करती है? बैकग्राउंड में आपके
पेलोड को चुपचाप डाउनलोड कर देती है। मतलब
तीसरा पॉइंट क्या था कि आप यह नहीं चाहते
कि जैसे आपने वो फाइल इनेबल कंटेंट किया।
आपका वीबीए मैक कोड एग्जीक्यूट हुआ और
स्क्रीन पर क्या आ गया? एक कम टर्मिनल ओपन
हो गया। उस पे कुछ कमांड रन हो गई और बंद
हो गया। आप यही नहीं चाहते यूज़र्स को नहीं
चाहते कि यूज़र्स को पता चले। तो आप क्या
करते हो? चुपचाप जो Wsipexe फाइल है उसको
इनवॉक करते हो। उसके थ्रू क्या करते हो?
एक वीबीएस का पेलोड पेलोड ड्रॉप करते हो।
वो ऑटोमेटिकली बैकग्राउंड में क्या करता
है? आपके लिए एक और पेलोड ड्रॉप करता है
और एग्जीक्यूट करता है।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? तो यह तीन रीजन है कि
जो हैकर्स है जो रेटिमर्स हैं
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट को
क्या चाहते हैं यूज करना या उनका फेवरेट
टूल है। पहला रीज़न क्या था कि आपको उसको
इंस्टॉल करने की जरूरत नहीं होती। वो
प्रीइस्टॉल्ड आता है। दूसरा क्या है कि आप
बैकग्राउंड में प्रोसेसिंग रन कर सकते हो।
किसी भी फाइल को रीड डिलीट कर सकते हो।
Windows रजिस्ट्री को रीच कर सकते हो।
इंटरनेट से फाइल डाउनलोड और एग्जीक्यूट कर
सकते हो। और तीसरा सबसेेंट क्या है कि आप
चुपचाप बिना यूज़र्स को कोई पॉपअप शो किए
हुए बैकग्राउंड में पेलोड ड्रॉप कर सकते
हो। ये सारे काम आप कर सकते हो। तो प्लीज
अंडरस्टुड सबको समझ में आ गया तीनों रीज़।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अभी मैं आपको बताता हूं कि व्हाट कैन यू
डू विद डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट? आप
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से क्या-क्या
कर सकते हो? डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से
आप क्या-क्या कर सकते हो? यूजिंग
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट यू कैन परफॉर्म ऑलमोस्ट
एनी टास्क ऑन Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स
दैट ए सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स और ए पावर
यूजर कैन डू विदाउट नीडिंग टू इंस्टॉल एनी
एक्स्ट्रा सॉफ्टवेयर।
मतलब डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से आप
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर बिना कोई
एक्स्ट्रा सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉल किए लगभग हर
वो काम कर सकते हो जो एक सिस्टम
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स या पावर यूजर कर सकता
है। आप लगभग हर एक वह काम कर सकते हो जो
एक सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स या एक पावर
यूज़र्स कर सकता है विथ द हेल्प ऑफ़ ए विद
दी हेल्प ऑफ
किसकी हेल्प से आप डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट की
हेल्प से
विद दी हेल्प ऑफ ए डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
विद द हेल्प ऑफ ए डब्लू स्क्रिप्ट वो सारे
काम कर सकते हो जैसे कि फॉर एग्जांपल्स
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम सिस्टम एडमिन आप
क्या कर सकते हो साइलेंट कमांड
एग्जीक्यूशंस हम बैकग्राउंड में पावर सेल
को रन कर सकते हैं। सीएमडी को रन कर सकते
हैं। कोई भी exc फाइल को बैकग्राउंड में
चुपचाप रन कर सकते हैं। बिना यूजर को कोई
टर्मिनल शो किए टर्मिनल दिखाए। दूसरा हम
क्या कर सकते हैं? हम
सिस्टम या जो यूज यूजर की जो रजिस्ट्री
कीज़ हैं उनको रीड कर सकते हैं, क्रिएट कर
सकते हैं, मॉडिफाई कर सकते हैं, डिलीट कर
सकते हैं। सिस्टम्स और यूज़र्स की जो
रजिस्ट्री कीज़ हैं, उनको चुपचाप रीड,
क्रिएट, मॉडिफाई और डिलीट भी कर सकते हैं।
विद द हेल्प ऑफ डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट। या हम
क्या कर सकते हैं? वी कैन क्फ़िगर
स्क्रिप्ट और एप्लीकेशन टू ल्च ऑटोमेटिकली
व्हनेवर द कंप्यूटर स्टार्ट। या हम कोई
ऐसी स्क्रिप्ट या एप्लीकेशन को कंफिगर कर
सकते हैं जो जैसे ही आपका सिस्टम स्टार्ट
होगा आपका सिस्टम बूट करेगा वो पर्टिकुलर
स्क्रिप्ट या पर्टिकुलर एप्लीकेशन क्या
करे रन करे तीसरा हम क्या कर सकते चौथा हम
क्या कर सकते हैं सिस्टम एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल्स को क्या कर सकते हैं मॉडिफाई कर
सकते हैं या उनको रीड कर सकते हैं जैसे
टेंप को पाथ को यूजरनेम ये सारे वेरिएबल्स
को भी क्या कर सकते हैं हम एनवायरमेंट
वेरिएबल्स को हम एक्सेस और मॉडिफाई कर
सकते हैं। और क्या कर सकते हैं हम? हम
क्या कर सकते हैं? फाइल एंड फोल्डर
ऑपरेशंस। हम फाइल्स को क्रिएट कर सकते
हैं। सिस्टम में रीड कर सकते हैं, राइट कर
सकते हैं, रीनेम कर सकते हैं, कॉपी कर
सकते हैं, डिलीट कर सकते हैं। दूसरा
ड्राइव के ऊपर हम किसी भी फाइल को सर्च कर
सकते हैं और रिट्रीव कर सकते हैं। थर्ड वन
हम क्या कर सकते हैं? सी ड्राइव के अंदर
या जो आपकी जो नेटवर्क ड्राइव है या आपका
जो पेन ड्राइव है उसका हम फ्री स्पेस चेक
कर सकते हैं। फाइल टाइप चेक कर सकते हैं।
टोटल स्पेस कितना है? ये सारी चीजें आप
क्या कर सकते हो? चेक कर सकते हो विद दी
हेल्प ऑफ डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट। बाकी क्या कर
सकते हो आप? आप करंट यूज़र्स चेक कर सकते
हो। पीसी होस्ट नेम चेक कर सकते हो।
डोमेनस की डिटेल फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो।
मतलब आप रिकॉन कर सकते हो। लोकल रिकॉर्न
कर सकते हो विद दी हेल्प ऑफ ए
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट। उसके बाद और क्या-क्या
कर सकते हो आप? आप बिल्ड इन कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट
का यूज कर सकते हो जो चुपचाप साइलेंटली
बैकग्राउंड में किसी भी बाइनरी को किसी भी
पेलोड को डाउनलोड कर देगा और एग्जीक्यूट
कर देगा। यह भी आप कर सकते हो। मतलब आप
वेब रिक्वेस्ट कर सकते हो विद दी हेल्प ऑफ
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट चुपचाप साइलेंटली।
और क्या कर सकते हो? आप स्क्रिप्ट बेस्ड
फाइल ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म कर सकते हो। जैसे कि
किसी भी फाइल को डायरेक्टली डिस्क के ऊपर
सेव करोगे। सेव करके उसके बाद उसको
एग्जीक्यूट करवा सकते हो इमीडिएटली। यह भी
आप काम कर सकते हो विद दी हेल्प ऑफ़
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट। उसके बाद और क्या कर
सकते हो आप? आप सोशल इंजीनियरिंग सिमुलेशन
परफॉर्म कर सकते हो। आप एरर्स जनरेट कर
सकते हो। वार्निंग पॉप अप करवा सकते हो।
इनेशन पॉप अप करवा सकते हो। मतलब जो
बिल्कुल देखने में जेन्युइन हो। मतलब फेक
ना लगे। मतलब हम हमारे लिए फेक होंगे
लेकिन देखने में फेक ना लगे। तो ये सारे
काम क्या कर सकते हो आप? डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
की हेल्प से कर सकते हो। ये सारे काम आप
डब्लू स्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से कर सकते हो।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? आप क्या-क्या कर सकते
हो डब्लू स्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से? सबको
क्लियर आ गया? क्लियर हो गया? समझ में आया
सबको?
सबको क्लियर हो गया कि हम
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट की हेल्प से क्या-क्या
कर सकते हैं। नहीं है डंप नहीं कर सकते
आप।
यह सारे काम इतना भी काफी है। एक वीबी की
हेल्प से
इतना भी काफी है। आपको इंफॉर्मेशन ज्यादा
चाहिए होती है। पेलोड ड्रॉप कर लिया तो
उसके बाद कर लोगे ना आप पेलोड से रिवर्स
कनेक्शन लेके सेल एक्सेस लेके।
नेक्स्ट यहां तक क्लियर है तो आगे बढ़े।
चलिए तो अभी हम बात करते हैं यह तो क्लियर
हो गया हमारा। अभी हम बात करते हैं वीबीए
मैक्रोस एंड क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स। वीबीए
मैक्रोच एंड क्लाइंट साइड मतलब अभी तक
हमने वीबीए के बारे में जो कुछ भी पढ़ा
सबको कंबाइन करके देखते हैं कि रेट टीम
इंगेजमेंट और रियल वर्ल्ड थ्रेट एक्टर्स
वीबीए मै को क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स में कैसे
वेपनाइज और लेवरेज करते हैं। आई एम
रिपीटिंग अगेन कि अभी तक हमने जो भी कुछ
पढ़ा है वीबीए के बारे में उसको अगर हम
कंबाइन करके देखें कि एक रेड टीम
इंगेजमेंट के दौरान या आपके जो रियल
हैकर्स होते हैं वो वीबीए मैक को क्लाइंट
चार्ट अटैक्स में कैसे वेपनाइज और लेवरेज
कर सकते हैं उसके बारे में डिस्कशन करते
हैं। तो इसके क्या है? चार प्राइमरी
पिलर्स हैं। सबसे पहला है आपका डिलीवरी
मैकेनिज्म। सबसे पहला आपका डिलीवरी
मैकेनिज्म मतलब मिलेशियस एक्टर्स ऑफन यूज
मैक एंबेडेड विद इन डॉक्यूमेंट्स एज
डिलीवरी मैकेनिज्म फॉर मालवेयर एज डिलीवरी
मैकेनिज्म फॉर मालवेयर मतलब क्या है कि जो
मिलेशियस एक्टर्स होते हैं अक्सर वो क्या
करते हैं डॉक्यूमेंट्स के अंदर मै को
एंबेड करते हैं और एंबेड करके
एंबेड करके वो क्या करते हैं डॉक्यूमेंट
को मालवेयर डिलीवर करने का एक मैकेनिज्म
के तौर पर यूज करते हैं। मतलब यह है कि जो
मिलिशियस एक्टर्स हैं, वह ऑफिस डॉक्यूमेंट
के अंदर मैक कोड को एंबेड करते हैं और
अपने मालवेयर को ऑफिस डॉक्यूमेंट के थ्रू
डिलीवर करने की कोशिश करते हैं या ड्रॉप
करने की कोशिश करते हैं। या उनका मानना है
कि जो मालवेयर डिलीवरी है उसको एक
मैकेनिज्म यह भी है कि आप मैक का यूज़ करें
ऑफिस के अंदर और उसके बाद उस मालवेयर को
ड्रॉप करवा लें। यह एक मैकेनिज्म का यूज़
करते हैं कौन हैकर्स। डिलीवरी मैकेनिज्म
के लिए यूज़ करते हैं किसका? मैक्रोज़ का।
एंड दी डॉक्यूमेंट्स आर टिपिकली
डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड बाय ईमेल और अदर चैनल
इनसिंग यूजर्स टू इनेबल मैक देयर बाय
एग्जीक्यूटिंग द एंबेडेड मिलसियस कोड। यह
डॉक्यूमेंट्स आमतौर पर या तो किसी फीसिंग
ईमेल के द्वारा भेजे जाते हैं या किसी
दूसरे चैनल्स जैसे कि कोई मिलसियस वेब
डाउनलोड्स के द्वारा क्या किए जाते हैं?
लिए डिस्ट्रीब्यूट किए जाते हैं जो किसी
भी यूज़र्स को मैक इनेबल करने के लिए
लुभाते हैं, एंटाइस करते हैं जिससे जो
आपका जो एंबेड मशियस कोड है वह एग्जीक्यूट
किया जा सके। मतलब क्या है कि या तो कोई
फिशिंग मेल में भेजा जाएगा या कोई ऐसा
मैकेनिज्म होगा जिसके थ्रू क्या होगा कि
जो यूज़र्स है यूज़र्स उस पे क्लिक करेगा।
क्लिक करने के बाद उसको ओपन करेगा। ओपन
करके लालच में आकर उस पर इनेबल कंटेंट
करेगा। इनेबल कंटेंट करने के बाद क्या
होगा? हमारा जो मालवेयर है, हमारा जो
पेलोड है, वो उसके ऊपर क्या हो जाएगा?
ड्रॉप हो जाएगा। तो, यह एक तरीका है जो
क्लाइंट में यूज़ किया जाता है। दूसरा हम
बात करते हैं सोशल इंजीनियरिंग की। पॉइंट
नंबर वन क्लियर है सबको? पॉइंट नंबर वन
क्लियर है सबको?
पॉइंट नंबर वन क्लियर है सबको?
पॉइंट नंबर वन क्लियर है? बताइए।
पॉइंट नंबर वन क्लियर है।
ओके। तो अभी आते हैं पॉइंट नंबर टू पर।
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। मैक्रोस आर
फ्रीक्वेंटली एंप्लॉयड इन सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अटैक्स। वेयर यूज़र्स आर
ट्रिग्ड इनू इनेबलिंग मैक्रोज़ अंडर द यूज़
ऑफ एक्सेसिंग कंटेंट और फंक्शनलिटी वििन द
डॉक्यूमेंट।
जो मिशियस एक्टर्स होते हैं, आमतौर पर
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक्स में मैकस का यूज
करते हैं। जहां यूज़र्स को डॉक्यूमेंट के
अंदर किसी कंटेंट या फंक्शनैलिटी को
एक्सेस करने के बहाने मैक इनेबल करने के
लिए ट्रिक किया जाता है। मतलब क्या है कि
वह क्या करते हैं कि यूजर को कोई ऐसा
बहाना देते हैं कि वह कि उन्हें कोई
कंटेंट देखना है या कोई फंक्शनैलिटी इनेबल
करनी है जिससे क्या होगा वो मैक को इनेबल
करेंगे और इनेबल इनेबल करने के लिए ट्रिक
किया जाता है सोशल इंजीनियर टैग के लिए
एंड वंस इनेबल द मैक मिलिशियस मैक
एग्जीक्यूट कॉम्प्रोमाइज द एंटायर यूजर
सिस्टम्स ओके और एक बार मैक इनेबल हो गया
तो जो मशियस मैक कोड है वह एग्जीक्यूट
होता है और यूजर के सिस्टम को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करने की कोशिश करता है। जब
तक यूजर उस पे इनेबल कंटेंट पर क्लिक नहीं
करता उसको अलऊ नहीं करता तब तक आपका मस
कोड एग्जीक्यूट नहीं होता। उसके लिए आप
क्या करते हो? अपने प्रिटेक्स क्वालिटी के
थ्रू उसको क्या करते हो? ट्रिक करते हो।
और जैसे ही यूजर क्या करता है? इनेबल
कंटेंट कर देता है। ठीक है? तो क्या होता
है? फिर आपका मै एग्जीक्यूट होता है और
एग्जीक्यूट होने के बाद वह आपके सिस्टम के
अंदर कोई पेलोड या कोई ऐसी स्क्रिप्ट रन
करता है कि आपके सिस्टम को कॉम्प्रोमाइज
करने की कोशिश करता है। बेसिकली जो
अटैकर्स होते हैं अटैकर्स इनेबल कंटेंट
वाली जो वार्निंग आती है ना उसको बायपास
करवाने के लिए सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का सहारा
लेते हैं यूजर से ट्रिक क्लिक करवाने के
लिए। पॉइंट नंबर टू क्लियर है?
पॉइंट नंबर टू क्लियर है?
पॉइंट नंबर टू क्लियर है।
तो अब आते हैं हम पॉइंट नंबर थ्री पर।
एक्सप्लइटिंग वनेरेबिलिटीज।
मैक्रोस मैक्रोस कैन एक्सप्लइट वनेबिलिटीज
इन क्लाइंट साइड एप्लीकेशन सच एज
Microsoft ऑफिस बाय लेवरेजिंग फीचर्स लाइक
माइक्रोस्क्रिप्टिंग एक्ट टू एक्स कंट्रोल
एंड एंबेडेड ऑब्जेक्ट
मतलब क्या है कि
जो मै जो मिशियस एक्टर्स होते हैं वह
मैक्रोज़ का यूज़ करके जो क्लाइंट साइड
एप्लीकेशनेशंस होती हैं जैसे आपका
Microsoft Office है, ऑफिस में एक्सेल है,
वर्ड है, पावर पॉइंट है, उसके अंदर जो
मौजूद वनेबिलिटीज़ हैं, उसको एक्सप्लइट
करते हैं। और फिर क्या करते हैं?
एक्सप्लइट करने के बाद वह डायरेक्ट
माइक्रोस्क्रिप्टिंग का यूज़ करते हैं या
जो एक्टिव एक्स कंट्रोल्स है या फिर जो
एंबेडेड ऑब्जेक्ट्स होते हैं जैसे जो
एडवांस फीचर्स हैं उनका फायदा उठाकर यूजर
के सिस्टम पर आर्बिट्रेरी कोड एग्जीक्यूट
करने की कोशिश करते हैं। मतलब क्या करते
हैं? पहले वह वनेबिलिटीज को फाइंड आउट
करते हैं। अगर उस पर्टिकुलर एप्लीकेशन के
अंदर वह वनेबिलिटीज मौजूद है, उसको
एक्सप्लइट करते हैं। और एक्सप्लइट करने के
बाद मैस्क्रिप्टिंग एक्ट टू एक्ट कंट्रोल
या जो ऑब्जेक्ट्स हैं जैसे जो एडवांस
फीचर्स हैं इसके वीबीए के मैक के उनका
फायदा उठाकर जो विक्टिम का जो सिस्टम है
जो टारगेट विक्टिम है उसके सिस्टम पर क्या
करते हैं? आर्बिट्रेरी कोड रन करने की
कोशिश करते हैं या फिर रन करते हैं। पॉइंट
नंबर फोर वो क्या करते हैं? पॉइंट नंबर
फोर में पेलोड डिलीवरी। मिलेशियस मैक्रोस
ऑफन सर्व एज ए पेलोड डिलीवरी मैकेनिज्म।
जैसे कि मैं पहले बता चुका हूं कि जो
मिलेशियस मैक्रोस अक्सर एक पेलोड डिलीवरी
मैकेनिज्म के तौर पर काम करते हैं।
ज्यादातर इनका मेन पर्पज क्या होता है?
किसी सिस्टम को कॉम्प्रोमाइज नहीं करना
होता। बस इनका काम क्या होता है? जैसे
इनेबल कंटेंट किया तो एक पेलोड को वो
ड्रॉप कर देंगे। मतलब एक पेलोड डिलीवरी के
तौर पर इनका काम किया जाता है। किसके ऊपर?
टारगेट सिस्टम के ऊपर। ओके? फैसिलिटेट इन
द एग्जीक्यूशन ऑफ़ मालवेयर और अदर मेशियस
एक्शन ऑन द विक्टिम सिस्टम। वंस मैक्रोस
आर इनेबल्ड, दे कैन डाउनलोड और एग्जीक्यूट
एडिशनल पेलोड फ्रॉम द रिमोट सर्वरर्स
लीडिंग टू फर्दर कॉम्प्रोमाइज। बेसिकली
क्या होता है कि यह क्या करते हैं कि
ज्यादातर किसी रिमोट सर्वर से एडिशनल
पेलोड डाउनलोड और डाउनलोड और एग्जीक्यूट
करने का काम करते हैं। डाउनलोड या
एग्जीक्यूट करने का काम करते हैं। या
मोस्ट मोस्ट ऑफ द टाइम क्या होता है कि जो
वर्ड है या जो एक्सेल फाइल है वह खुद
मालवेयर नहीं होते। आपका जो वर्ड और
एक्सेल फाइल है देखो MS Word है जो आपका
MS Word है
और यह जो आपकी एक्सेल फाइल है
मोस्ट ऑफ द टाइम होता क्या है कि यह खुद
मालवेयर नहीं है। यह खुद मालवेयर नहीं है।
यह क्या करते एक स्टेजर या ड्रॉपर का काम
करते हैं। यह स्टेजर या ड्रॉपर का काम
करते हैं। और जैसे ही वह डॉक्यूमेंट ओपन
होता है और इनेबल कंटेंट होता है तो उसके
अंदर एक वीबीए मैक कोड रन होता है। वो
क्या करता है? डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट का यूज़
करता है। डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट का यूज़ करके
पावर सेल को ओपन करता है। ल्च करता है।
पावर सेल बैकग्राउंड में क्या करती है? C2
सर्वर से कम्युनिकेट करती है। C2 सर्वर से
क्या किया जाता है एक पेलोड डाउनलोड किया
जाता है और पेलोड डाउनलोड करने के बाद
उसको किसी डिस्क पिक लोकेशन पे सेव किया
जाता है। उसके बाद उसको एग्जीक्यूट किया
जाता है। उसको एग्जीक्यूशन के लिए सेटअप
किया जा किया जाता है। ये इस पर्पस के लिए
ज्यादातर मैक्रोज़ का यूज़ किया जाता है।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? सबको
समझ में आ गया कि क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स में
मैक्रोज़ का कैसे यूज़ किया जाता है?
क्लाइंट अटैक्स में मैक्रोस का कैसे यूज़
किया जाता है?
पता चल गया। तो अब बात करते हैं इस लेक्चर
का की टेकवेज। की टेकवेज ये है कि
रिगार्डलेस ऑफ द फाइल एक्सटेंशन Microsoft
Office इंटरनल पासिंग इंजन वैलिडेट द
एक्चुअल इंटरनल एक्सM स्ट्रक्चर। तो पॉइंट
नंबर वन आपको ध्यान में रखना है कि अब
फाइल एक्सटेंशन चाहे जो भी हो जो
Microsoft Office है वो इस डीएलएल
लाइब्रेरी का यूज़ करता है उसकी इंटरनल
एक्सML स्ट्रक्चर को वैलिडेट करने के लिए।
पॉइंट नंबर टू आपको क्या ध्यान रखना है?
जो आपका वीबीए मैक है और जो सिस्टम लेवल
ऑपरेशंस है उनके बीच में आपका जो
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है वह एक ब्रिज का काम
करता है। पॉइंट नंबर थ्री में कि जो आपका
मैक है उसका प्राइमरी काम होता है एक विकल
की तरह पेलोड को क्या करना? डिलीवर करना।
पेलोड को डिलीवर करना। और पेलोड डिलीवरी
के लिए या एक ड्रॉपर काम के लिए हम क्या
करते हैं? सोशल इंजन जैसी टेक्निक का यूज
करते हैं। आप आपके मेलो आपका जो मैक कोड
एग्जीक्यूशन में अगर आपको यूजर से मै
इनेबल करवाना है उसको कोड को एग्जीक्यूट
करवाना है तो हम सोशल इंजीनियरिंग जैसी
टेक्निक का यूज़ करते हैं क्लाइंट्स एंड
अटैक के अंदर। तो तीन चीजें फाइल
एक्सटेंशन चेंज करने का कोई फायदा नहीं
है। आपका जो डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है वह एक
ब्रिज का काम करता है। थर्ड वन आपका जो
मैक्रोज़ है वह एक डिलीवरी मैकेनिज्म का
काम करता है। बेसिकली पेलोड के लेके
सिस्टम पर ड्रॉप करना। ज्यादातर इसी पर्पज
के लिए यूज किया जाता है। यहां तक सबको
समझ में आ गया? किसी को डाउट है तो प्लीज
मुझसे पूछ सकते हैं। आज की क्लास का टॉपिक
इतना ही था।
बताओ
कोई डाउट है? यह फंडामेंटल क्लियर हो गया।
अभी हम नेक्स्ट क्लास में क्या करेंगे?
अपने प्रैक्टिकल पर जाएंगे।
प्रैक्टिकली परफॉर्म करेंगे सारी चीजें।
तो किसी को फंडामेंटल में डाउट है? सबको
आज का सेशन समझ में आ गया। डब्ल्यू
स्क्रिप्ट क्या होती है? डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
और वीबीए के बीच में क्या कनेक्शन है? और
डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट के साथ आप क्या-क्या
काम कर सकते हो? पेंटेस्टस रेटिमस
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट का क्यों यूज़ करते हैं?
और उसके बाद क्लाइंट सेट अटैक्स में
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट क्यों यूज़ की जाती है?
यार यह मैं पीडीएफ प्रोवाइड नहीं करवा पा
रहा हूं क्योंकि एप्लीकेशन का साइज कम है
और मेरे नोट्स का साइज बहुत ज्यादा पड़
जाता है।
आई अंडरस्टुड मुझे पता है क्योंकि मैं
एप्लीकेशन आगे जो नोट्स डाउनलोड करता हूं
अराउंड वो मेरा एप्लीकेशन का साइज अराउंड
40 MB रहता है। तो प्रॉब्लम ये है कि जो
मेरे नोट्स हैं अगर उनकी क्वालिटी डाउन
करूंगा मैं। क्वालिटी डाउन करने के बाद
क्या होता है कि आप जो मैंने कुछ नोट्स
डिटेल्स में बनवाए हैं जिसमें छोटे-छोटे
एआई का यूज करके आपके लिए पोस्टर्स बनवाए
हैं तो पोस्टर्स में कुछ दिखेगा नहीं। कोई
फायदा नहीं होगा।
यह नोट x मुझसे एक सवाल कर रहे हैं कि सर
doc वाले फाइल को अगर मैं रिनेम करके docx
बना दूं तो फाइल ओपन होगा अगर होगा तो
माइक्रो रन होगा क्या
आप कल की क्लास में थे
अगर आप कल की क्लास में थे तो यह सवाल आप
पूछ ही नहीं सकते और आपके मन में सवाल आना
ही नहीं चाहिए।
कल की क्लास में अगर आपने क्लास को ध्यान
से देखा होगा। अनोनिमस आप कल की क्लास में
थे।
अनोनिमस जगत गुरु जी या बाकी लोग कल की
क्लास में थे। तो जो सवाल नो x ने पूछा है
क्या? यह सवाल कल की क्लास में डिस्कस हुआ
था। सेम सवाल
सेम सवाल डिस्कस हुआ था। सेम सवाल
हुआ था। बिल्कुल एग्जैक्ट सेम कुछ भी चेंज
हुआ था डिस्कस
तो अभी आप नोड x अब यह सवाल डिस्कस हुआ था
तो आपको यह सवाल समझ में तब नहीं आया था।
आपके दिमाग के सवाल मैं पहले सोच चुका
होता हूं। दोस्तों
मुझे पता ना आप क्या सोच सकते हो। तो अगर
मैंने आपके सवाल का जवाब दिया था।
यहां पर दो दो पॉसिबिलिटीज हैं। या तो आप
क्लास में प्रेजेंट नहीं थे।
ठीक है? या तो आप प्रेजेंट नहीं थे। आपने
उसको ध्यान से नहीं समझा। या फिर आपको समझ
में नहीं आया था तो आपको पूछना चाहिए था।
ठीक है?
Google पर सर्च किया तो Google पर सर्च
करने की कोई भी रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं थी
क्योंकि मैंने उसको समझाया है और सवाल को
बहुत अच्छे से समझाया है। तो यह तो यार
आपने तो मैं क्या बोलूं अभी आप ही बताओ।
बाकी लोग बताओ कि मुझे क्या बोलना चाहिए?
क्या इन पर डांट नहीं मारनी चाहिए मुझे?
क्योंकि एग्जैक्ट सेम सवाल मैंने पूछा था
और जवाब भी दिया था आप लोगों को। बिल्कुल
डिटेल्ड वे में एक्सप्लेन किया था। और
आकाश जी पूछते साहब क्या पढ़ा रहे हो?
आप नए हो तो हम पढ़ा रहे हैं डीईएचई
डेफोनिक्स एथिकल हैकिंग सीरीज। इसमें पूरा
फ्री एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स करवाया जा रहा
है। बिल्कुल जीरो से लेकर। बिल्कुल। क्लास
वन से लेकर स्टार्ट किया था। अगर आप क्लास
वन से देखोगे तो बिल्कुल एक इंटरमीडिएट
लेवल तक का कोर्स है यह। अगर आप कोई भी
ईजीपीटी कोई भी जूनियर लेवल पेन टेस्टिंग
सर्टिफिकेशन की तैयारी कर रहे हो, जूनियर
लेवल पेन टेस्टिंग या जॉब की तैयारी कर
रहे हो या ओएससीपी की ही क्यों ना तैयारी
कर रहे हो तो उसके जो फंडामेंटल्स हैं,
उसके जो टॉपिक्स है, उसके जो कंटेंट्स है,
आपको जो बेसिक फंडामेंटल या उसकी लैब
सॉल्व करने के लिए, एग्जाम देने के लिए जो
चीज की रिक्वायरमेंट है, वह सारी चीजें
इसके अंदर अवेलेबल है।
ओके भूल गया होगा टेंशन में टेंशन में
क्या है इतना इजी समझाता हूं नोट बताओ
बताओ आप गायब ही हो गया अब
ओके एनोनिमस पूछ रहे हैं सर की टेक अवे
में पॉइंट नंबर वन क्या था पॉइंट नंबर वन
यह था कि अभी आपकी जो फाइल एक्सटेंशनंस
चाहे कोई भी हो आपका जो डीएलएल फाइल है जो
मैंने आपको बताया था www वाली डॉट वाली जो
फाइल थी वो उस फाइल चाहे एक्सटेंशन कोई भी
हो वो क्या करती है इंटरनल स्ट्रक्चर के
बेस पर ही डिसीजन लेती है कि फाइल रन होगी
या नहीं होगी अंडरस्टुड
यार ट्रांसलेशन कहां से बंद होता मुझे
बताओ यार
मुझे ट्रांसलेशन का देखना पड़ेगा।
मुझे देखता हूं उसका कुछ करता हूं।
तो किसी कोई और सवाल है? कुछ पूछना चाहते
हो आप?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
कुछ पूछना चाहते हो?
सेटिंग में ऑप्शन है।
ओके इसको बाद में
हम हम
बाद में देख सकता हूं मैं इसको अभी नहीं
देख सकता सेटिंग में
एनोनिमस ने पोसासर फायरवाल को बायपास कर
सकते हैं। तो एनोनिमस मैं आपसे एक सवाल
पूछता हूं। क्या हम सोशल इंजीनियरिंग से
फायरवाल को बायपास कर सकते हैं?
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग से अगर आपने किसी
एंप्लॉय को
ट्रिगर किया, ट्रिक किया
तो क्या हम कर सकते हैं?
बस फिर आपको अपना जवाब मिल गया होगा।
इस पर आखिर में इनेबल कंटेंट फायर वाल
थोड़ी ना कर रहा है।
बाकी
किसी को और कोई सवाल कोई डाउट? फिर हम
प्रैक्टिकल स्टार्ट करेंगे कल से मतलब कि
नेक्स्ट क्लास से।
देख लो अगर आप लोग
डीएचई की रेगुलर सीरीज करना चाहते हो।
जैसे नॉर्मल क्लास की तरह जैसे हर सेकंड
डे, थर्ड डे की क्लास आए। मैं कर सकता
हूं। बट उसके लिए मुझे स्ट्रेंथ और चाहिए।
उसके लिए हम
उसके लिए मुझे 10 पांच लोगों से काम नहीं
चलेगा। स्टूडेंट्स आने चाहिए। इंटरेस्ट
दिखाना चाहिए और आप लोग मुझे एक आप लोगों
से छोटी सी रिक्वेस्ट है। आप सच में चाहते
हो कि कि ज्यादा से ज्यादा लोग इसको देखें
तो प्लीज आपके कमेंट, इसकी पोस्ट और इसकी
शेयर और इसको लाइक बहुत मैटर करता है।
किसी वीडियो पर लाइक और कमेंट नहीं होते
ना
वह वीडियो ज्यादातर लोग उसको सोचते हैं कि
नथिंग इस वीडियो में कुछ नहीं है क्योंकि
आपके लाइक्स उन सब चीजें बहुत मैटर करता
है
चलिए फिर अगर आपका कोई भी डाउट नहीं है तो
सेशन को एंड करते हैं फिर ओके तो नेक्स्ट
सेशन में मिलेंगे प्रैक्टिकल सेशन स्टार्ट
करेंगे और इसके प्रैक्टिकल्स मैं सोच रहा
हूं कि कैसे करवाने हैं पहले आपको बेसिक
करवाऊंगा उसके बाद हम डेडिकेटेड टू
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स करेंगे
उसके बाद आपके वेब्स वाले भी टॉपिक करवाने
हैं ना कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट इंपोर्टेंट
ऑथेंटिकेशन
या कुछ और भी जो इंपॉर्टेंट इंपोर्टेंट है
करवाने हैं ना
वो भी कर लेंगे।
चलिए फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं। बाय-ब
एवरीवन एंड गुड नाइट एवरीवन एंड सी यू फॉर
नेक्स्ट सेशन। जब भी आपका नेक्स्ट सेशन
होगा तो आपको इनफॉर्म कर दिया जाएगा ग्रुप
में। प्लीज बाय-ब एवरीवन।